way here with reaction house Speaker uh
former house speaker and Fox News
contributor new kingr is with us Mr
Speaker good to have you thank you let
me let me start with Israel today um to
me the biggest threat is originally the
fear of the Israelis is they'd be
fighting a two-front war in the North
Lebanon Hezbollah again funded by Iran
uh in the South it's Gaza Hamas again
Iranian uh fingerprints all over that
conflict now you have the added Direct
threat of an attack by Iran itself uh
what that would mean for the region I
can't predict but it certainly would not
be good and and could lead I think to an
allout bigger conflict your
thoughts well I hope that the reason
President Biden sent two nuclear carrier
battle groups which is an enormous
amount of combat power into the Eastern
Mediterranean is to make clear that if
Hezbollah attacks Israel that they will
be annihilated and I would hope that
we're communicating the same thing to
Iran uh if this becomes people need to
remember if this became an existential
fight for the survival of Israel Israel
has nuclear weapons Israel is not going
to peacefully accept a second Holocaust
and so folks in Iran are playing with
with very dangerous circumstances in
terms of what's going on I would hope
the United States will make very clear
that if we had to reluctantly but we
would in sure that a northern front
never developed and that Hezbollah was
annihilated which we have the capacity
to do in those two new two nuclear
carrier but I have a tough question for
you the thing that worries me is is Joe
Biden capable of hearing your very wise
advice here that is that to prevent a
wider scale War do you think he has the
strength to do it my sources in Israel
have been telling me repeatedly that the
Biden Administration and that would be
Tony blinkin and that would be Joe Biden
they are saying the right things
publicly privately they are urging
Israel to show restraint uh so if that's
the case I'm not sure that Joe Biden
would be the guy to do
that look that was the second thing I
was going to get to I mean the first
thing is they have sent two carrier
battle groups Biden has said clearly
over and over do not do this in terms of
Hezbollah and Iran now at some point
you'll get to a point where either he
either Acts or he looks like a total
complete fool and I think at that point
he will not have much choice in terms of
the meeting I'm worried about the
meeting uh that tomorrow today in Israel
uh because I think the Israelis have to
be reassured that whatever steps are
necessary to eliminate Hamas the United
States will support not this you know do
as much as you can while being
reasonable if Hamas is still around a
year from now Israel will have been
defeated and the United States will have
been defeated so so this is the moment
to calmly and methodically eliminate
Hamas as a system to do whatever it
takes to achieve that and I am totally
in favor of the Israelis being very calm
very methodical very deliberate but
getting the job done and I hope that
Biden is not going to suggest to them
that they do anything less than the
complete destruction of
Hamas okay let let me let me ask you
this and and I
saw newsletter that I maybe I saw an
early copy of it I don't really know but
a lot of things are going on as it
relates to speaker Jim Jordan got 200
votes today I think he would have needed
216 if I'm correct um now you have
Alexandria Casio Cortez you know
tweeting out if you don't want Jim
Jordan to be speaker contact the 20
contact your representative in other
words the 20 Republicans that didn't
vote for him today uh Jeff is saying we
have two objectives stop Jim Jordan and
and get back to work then you have the
Lincoln project uh and they don't want
Jim Jordan as Speaker uh then you have
hakee Jeff an election denier himself uh
you know using the the Maga Republican
line the one thing that I I might find
myself in a little bit of disagreement
with you which we are not we don't often
disagree you seem to be open to the idea
of a Band-Aid or a temporary fix or the
the speaker Pro Tam now McKenry from
North Carolina filling that role being
empowered for 60 90 days to me that is
not Republican leadership I think they
need to stay in a room and never come
out until they pick a speaker and you
know white smoke comes out of the uh uh
the chimney that would be a a good idea
in my view and secondly uh I think it's
very very important that they get this
job done and show the country that they
can make tough decisions that they can
Unite with their small
majority and win I think you're
disagreeing with me on
that no look I I think if Jim Jordan if
he has a chance tomorrow if they vote
tomorrow if he can get the 2117 votes I
am all for him I think he's a smart guy
I think he's a very solid conservative I
think he's reached out and tried to
become a very broad leader in a way that
he would be I think a very strong
Speaker of the House the point I've made
in my newsletter which is coming out of
of
Gish 360 tonight is pretty
straightforward if Jordan can't win and
if scalise can't win then first of all
the people you should really blame are
the eight Republicans who are Benedict
Arnolds who were traitors who joined
with the Democrats to cause total chaos
with no idea what was going to come next
those PE those eight people didn't have
a clue what they were unleashing and
they had no plan for how to put it back
together and now now they've legitimized
if they get to be idiots everybody else
gets to be an idiot and suddenly you
have a party looking at each other
yelling at each other and being pretty
angry about the state they're in the
only argument I think that for McKenry
is if you cannot get an agreement
tomorrow in Jordan the world is moving
as you we just talked about Israel's in
a big war Ukraine is in a war China's on
offense the why if need be why not have
15 votes if need be why not do what they
did with McCarthy
wow well if I thought that would work I
would be for 15 votes I'd be for 15
votes frankly to bring McCarthy back the
fact is I have no faith that you can put
this together right now now again if I'm
all for Jordan having an opportunity
tomorrow I hope he can win I'd much
rather have a new speaker than have a
speaker proem but I wrote my newsletter
on the grounds that my hunch is that 200
votes is about what he's going to get
200 votes uh is much higher than scalise
got and scales was the majority leader
uh and my sense from talking to people
in the house tonight is that in the next
vote he might actually get fewer not
more votes if that happens we can't sit
around and suck our thumbs and hope the
world will wait until the House
Republicans get their act together you
you're every day we're closer to the end
of the continuing resolution every every
day we're closer to a huge age package
uh for for Israel that has to be passed
every day we are failing to do the
investigations we need to be doing and
so if in a worst case I think that we've
had our two best shots scalise and
Jordan if Jordan can win I am totally
for him this is not to undercut him and
Jim is a good guy he's a very
competitive guy as you know he's 156 to
one uh in high school wrestling he was
twice the NCAA Wrestling Champion for
the country he's a very competitive very
smart guy but I also understand numbers
and if and I I quit because I had 19
guys who thought that balancing the
budget reforming welfare cutting taxes
wasn't enough I wasn't conservative
enough for them so I understand how this
game is played and I'm just saying it's
a numbers game given the current narrow
Republican majority unless they can get
in a room and get everybody to agree and
frankly there are a lot of people who
are relative ly normal who are now so
angry at the eight guys who betrayed
them that it's very hard for them to
have a rational conversation and my only
point is maybe you need a couple months
of just getting business done being calm
having an interim caretaker and
understanding that maybe by January you
can have a rational decision I think
they give uh in my opinion that'll come
off a Band-Aid solution a temporary
solution if in fact they get that done
to me shows that they are are weak that
they're not leaders or if they if any
Republicans work with hakee Jeff and the
Democrats you know they're showing
Republicans and the American people they
can't they can't handle the power that
has been entrusted to them and they and
that's a shame I'll give second no it
isn't no you're right this is a sign of
weakness not strength it's a sign of
immaturity it's a sign of what happens
when you have eight traitors sitting in
the middle of your of your group uh and
nobody's been able to figure out a
solution I'm just suggesting maybe time
out in a few months to calm down is the
only way forward not the best way the
only way we'll put the children in
timeout that's what it sounds like
probably the appropriate term all right
I hope it doesn't come to that I I hope
they see seize the moment and understand
that the people's house needs to open uh
we'll see you tomorrow thank you sir hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else